vladimir putin's very much aware of the
possibility of a coup
bloodless or bloody against him
he's allegedly obsessed by the overthrow
of libyan dictator mumar gaddafi and
desperately wants to avoid that fate
joining me now is buck sexton former cia
analyst and co-host of the clay travis
and buck sexton show along with retired
u.s marine johnny joey jones
so buck i mean he could get a bullet in
his head he could get poisoned he loves
poison over there you know that or they
could just maybe send him to siberia
what kind of preparations do you think
putin's made to prevent that
there are very few people on earth who
spend more time thinking about their
personal security than vladimir putin
this would be tough and i know people
right now might be thinking a palace
coup wouldn't that be fantastic that
could possibly end this whole thing but
that i think is a distant possibility at
best right now there's simply not enough
of the people around putin who would
have suffered pain nor have the russian
people seen enough in terms of
casualties to be willing to deal with
the incredible force of the fsb the
russian internal security service
they're very good at repression and
they're also very good at keeping the
big guy in charge and for anybody around
him and it is true if you look at the
academic literature authoritarians
usually do fall by people around them
and they're in their orbit people that
they have trusted but if you come at the
king you best not miss and if you come
at vladimir putin obviously your whole
family's in jeopardy so this is
something i think we might see down the
line jesse but we'd be
far too lucky for him to get pushed
aside right now yeah i agree it's way
too early but let's just game plan this
out
jones if if they just start chewing up
russian soldiers in a vicious western
funded insurgency and the ruble is
garbage and there's lines and people
can't leave the country and there's
chaos on the streets and the oligarchs
you know they can't rub two singles
together
when does the security state in russia
make a move
on vlad
you know buck's gonna know a lot more
about this than me but i'll tell you
it's not hard to see
that putin's power comes from the power
he continues to secure by those around
and the oligarchs aren't suppressed for
information they can spend as much time
here as they do in russia they
their wealth allows them to travel the
world they understand more probably more
clearly than than most of us do who
putin is and the positive and negative
effect he has on his country that's kind
of the irony in this is that the people
who are in vast numbers and don't have
the resources and are down trotting the
most by a dictator like this have the
least amount of information
but when we go after the oligarchs
that's when the tide may get the change
i guess my biggest problem is we can't
look at this as a u.s strategy right we
can't say well he's not going to send
nukes because before he does they're
going to kill him themselves that's
that's not a us strategy that's not how
we defend ourselves and the fact that
we're having to have this conversation
because it seems like there's not a lot
of other plays among our government
that's what's concerning and that's what
bothers me in fact we're at prime time
television
and we're looking at well maybe they'll
kill putin themselves or get rid of them
themselves as a strategy isn't that kind
of the problem jesse i mean that doesn't
that kind of tell you where we are with
it yeah i mean until he goes after a
nato ally you just got to let him sink
in ukraine and just just wreck their
banking system from abroad that's the
only play so buck you're going to see
the president
you know come into the chamber and he's
going to be shaking hands and everyone's
going to be mugging for the camera and
get that shot of them close to them they
can push out and their little pamphlets
for re-election although i don't see why
that would even help
what do you think the president has to
say to the american people tonight about
ukraine
that makes sense to them because yes
you know we want russia to die on this
hill and we want to you know we want a
victory for the ukrainian people
but at what expense you know we're
getting crushed by high gas prices and
high oil prices here and we're probably
going to see a supply chain problem when
they can't feed europe and the mid east
how does he sell what he's doing in
ukraine is a success
jesse i think he's going to have a lot
of trouble selling anything that he's
done in the first year or so of the
administration as a success the border
crime the economy inflation you name it
on ukraine specifically he said people
go back and see the video in 2019 putin
doesn't want me to be president putin's
scared of me he'll never do anything bad
these are the kind of things that come
back to haunt politicians especially
when you're talking about matters of war
and peace this is a president this is an
administration that doesn't see the
world as it is and has clearly not
outmaneuvered vladimir putin
diplomatically not outmaneuvered him in
terms of the global chess game that's
always underway and i think that you're
going to see tonight biden try to
project strength perhaps whisper
aggressively at people use the word
folks a lot and generally just project
more weakness all right we'll see
tonight we'll be watching thank you guys
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else